la boue jour je m'appelle apollo j'ai 11
ans et je suis en cinquième
[Musique]
ma maladie c'est une gamme assez
recovery canaux pâtit le nom il un peu
compliqué mais c'est une maladie des
ceintures à la ceinture des hanches et
des épaules et c'est une maladie
d'origine génétique dégénérative
ça veut dire que mon état empire chaque
jour et pas forcément moment je pourrais
je pourrais peut marcher je serai
dépendants de nos fauteuils
[Musique]
il ya plusieurs choses que je peux pas
faire même par exemple ou pas un
fauteuil manuel ça ne servira pas à
grand chose parce que j'ai du mal à
avancer avec mes bras tous seuls donc
j'ai déjà en fauteuil électrique mais je
veux m'en ça je veux pas m'en servir
justement je veux marcher le plus
possible même si ce sera plus tard qu'un
jour par un pas par jour je veux marcher
tant que je peux ma maman m'a dit un peu
après que j'aie le diagnostic de
maladies
il m'a dit une phrase qui m'a beaucoup
marqué et elle m'a dit ton corps c'est
comme une enveloppe et le mental c'est
le plus important
donc il faut toujours regarder le côté
positif des choses
faut voir le verre à moitié remplie et
parce que si on voit parce que on peut
s'apitoyer sur son sort mais ça
servirait à rien on se rendrait triste
pour rien
c'est par là et les chercheurs font déjà
leur maximum ils peuvent cas il y à plus
de 3500 maladie diagnostiquée ils
peuvent pas prendre chaque cas est
trouvé en
man court instant chaque médicament et
il y en a encore autant à découvrir donc
je sais que moi je fais partie de la
liste d'attentes pour trouver un
traitement
là forcément un jour où il y aura
quelque chose
j'aimerais
tout ce qui est dans le domaine des
sciences j'aime beaucoup ça et
j'aimerais m'investir dans la recherche
des médicaments contre la maladie
ce que c'est devenu mon combat contre
quotidien est qu un jour si je peux
bénéficier d'un traitement j'aimerais
que d'autres personnes aient le même la
même surprise le même cadeau de pouvoir
avoir un traitement
[Musique]